i loved it it was really nice i never
really had a chance to walk around
toronto before this because i grew up in
brampton and
this was the first time i really kind of
got to know the city like knew my way
around
and found some good spots and felt like
i actually lived here you know
so it was really nice oh it was great um
i've had
like the best vegan food ever here um
it's really amazing um it's an amazing
city and um
i'm uh i'm glad i'm not in the same
hotel because i think that would just be
a little too weird
so it's it's cool just driving back the
the streets like towards the center of
town it was like that warm feeling
hey what's up i'll leave you alone
forever now
it was amazing you know i've only been
here uh for short visits
for the toronto film festival and i used
to play in a band and we would come here
but only for a night or something
you know i love this place i have some
friends here that are in a band called
sloan
and i've always they've always taken me
out for a dinner or something you know
and
gone to their rehearsal space and i've
always looked around and said man
i'd love to spend more than 48 hours
here you know and for this movie i got
to shoot
you know shoot and stay here for almost
three months it was so much fun i mean
such good shopping in restaurants and it
was kind of the perfect place for a
group of young actors
to be together because there was always
something to do and always a place to
hang out and i i love it here
and i have to fight defeat your feet
your seven evil exes pretty much
prepare to die what
[Music]
oh what's up how's life he seems nice
you'll probably hear about this from all
the other cast members because that's
like all we talk about is how amazing
the food was here
you know i love walking like through
parks and like queen street west and
fellwood's park and um
you know sonic boom and um
saving grace which is an amazing
breakfast restaurant i had a really
wonderful time and
came came to know so many nice people
and so many great stores and
especially for musicians so many great
music stores like this store paul's
boutique
and capsule music and oh it's just the
best